the club has received the secretion a
request by someone to honor two of the
best lady players of all time they are
still with us thank goodness so it's not
dead legend becsher
it's referring to the georgian
grandmasters nona gaprindashvili and my
attribute uh needs a both were world
champion respectfully and respectively
and we will see some of their games more
than anything I think that you will find
out that typically two woman's just it's
very aggressive a little bit coffee
houses and again the at the level of
grandmas of course they understand
everything they know more than just that
but king hunting is very popular and you
will see it in our game the first game I
like the finish but I have to say I like
a resourcefulness I think she was
playing for a win against a more rated
opponent with the black pieces she was
willing to take risks and she was in
trouble actually white was better but
again the burden of proof was on white
and it was very hard to pass the test
why didn't so she's playing lazarevich
from what used to be Yugoslavia
so f4 already not compromising she's
black c5 Knight f3 g6 again a very good
system just in case white wanted to try
to play something like the b3 f4 night
of three this is kind of a good way to
mess up with that so three Bishop g7 d3
white is playing a bit passively but not
abnormal he's six already a bit
compromising notice that you already
have g6 in the bishop here but she
doesn't want to put the knight on f6
where he doesn't have that much of a
future she prefers to plutonomy seven
multiple flexible here here
castles knight c6 e for one would wonder
why wasn't that played immediately d3
and d4 but we will never find the answer
d say
see three castles Bishop to e3 roof
being very similar to the concept behind
a closed Sicilian Black is intending to
play the moves b5 b4 and do its worst on
the queenside where he has the advantage
so white plays d4 not my favorite move
most favorite move in this position I
think it made sense to play a four to
provoke a six and then to just play 9 BD
to wait until the right moment to just
play 9 c4 if you can 95 if you if we
eventually get hit by d5 ok d4 now it's
time for black to do something because
if I'm gonna get to go d5 myself right
now very questionable what the knight on
c6 is gonna land
so f5 immediately hitting July it
squares be 5 takes takes 95 needless to
say that black is not intending to play
pawn to d5 here after which is Bishop on
c8 is gonna look very very French slash
Queens gambit declined like so 95
attacking the bishop the bishop retreats
to c1 and again in this position it's
more or less sequel but it's very close
the bishop on g7 is pacified the bishop
on C it is a bit weak the question is
how to do something she starts Bishop 8
6 very provocative play again to tell
you that this is the best move I'm not
sure that I can but again I really like
the attitude when you're playing a lower
rated player you're blocked your
opponent is wide you have to try to
create some nagging chances and this is
what she does ok g3 now she took on e5
again maybe hoping for Fe f4 because
that's not going to happen so it takes
with the D pawn and B 5 action on both
sides now I played Knight c3 reasonable
move Queen b6 checking in a move that
needs no explanation developing the
Queen King moves and rook d8 again
it's easy to be critical in hindsight
but I think that if I was white if I was
black I would first take the knight on
c3 caused some damage to the pawn
structure then go route d8 basically
because I believe that it's going to be
very hard for Y to occupy d4 before I
generate all my play on the Queen side
but she opted to play this so takes
takes Queen b3 again in this position
white is doing quite okay no question
about it
Bishop f8 again in anticipation of the
move Bishop e3 so Bishop e3 Bishop to c5
really normal takes takes rook d1 again
in this position you're wondering okay
what's a big deal about this game and
the big deal is that black is trying to
win it and she's gonna just do
everything in their capacities try to
get something moving here so 97 again
the only move if I get to take twice
from d5 and then rook c1 of course white
is the only one playing for a win so 97
rook c1 Queen b6 takes an takes so for
now we see the Black has managed to get
some sort of an initiative the knight on
d5 is multifold better than the knight
on f3 but you notice that there's some
tactics in this position and white
correctly plays this move Queen takes b5
you notice that Bishop c8 is hanging in
the case of Queen takes b5 roof take C
it might be inconvenient so Queen e3
that's what she was banking on because
otherwise you'd wonder you wonder okay
what else can you play you lost the pawn
and what are you gonna do while you're
gonna move this bishop you can't take
the Queen you can't I mean you it looks
like you're really stuck so after takes
takes and the bishop on c8 of course I
meant to say take bishop takes if you
take them rook c8 yeah so she was
banking it on the move Queen to e3
sacrificing not only a pawn but also the
exchange with the hope of messing things
up again
is a great attitude I think by that by
the second player but objectively it
really should not have worked but again
it's very hard for white apply so at
first she thought for a long time and
played Queen to be eight I think that if
she would have played Queen to d8 I
don't know exactly what black would have
done to win but I think that it would
have been pretty hard I think this this
should guarantee at least a draw
Queen e8 not one not at least just a
draw Queenie 8th King g7 and then I'm
assuming rooks g7 check right and I have
a perpetual so yeah but she decides to
take takes king f1 and now King g7 very
brave play this King you're now becoming
a part of the attack and of course Queen
takes c8 Queen takes f3 is very very
messy with 93 coming so now White has to
be on her toes now when you put it in
the computer the computer is very
confident shows you exactly what you're
supposed to do but when you're human
it's much much harder I'm just curious
just intuitively if you had white in
this position what would you play let's
see here some suggestion just to see
again I'm not giving you a whole lot of
time to try to solve it saying she had
white had plenty of time on the clock
although not infinite but just
intuitively throw a move okay
other ideas everybody else I want to
hear any was it Arjun
Queen takes e8 okay anything else one
per customer Arjun have you ever managed
to make two moves on your board at once
no I don't think so say rook to c3 maybe
9 takes c3 messy you can get into a mate
map
so you see you guys suggest that the
trivial moves but none of you suggested
to move that the computers adjusted but
the convenience is just this move
because it's just so simple Queen b3
after Queen b3 the computer says that
white is just winning but
well eventually but she didn't find it
and it's very easy to go wrong I think
that Quincy ate Queen of three is
dangerous I think rooks III takes and
Queen eight seven was played in the game
so here King eight six and in this
position she played queer a3 trying to
defend the night I think this is one
move too late already the position of
the white thing is a bit precarious you
have to be careful about what you do
because black has a very simple idea
you'll see it coming after Queen 1883 I
think this is not easy already for white
I think Queen takes a 7 was I think it's
a mistake in my opinion I think simply
Queen B 3 and yeah so Queen a3 and black
plays King h5 very imaginative this is
really really a smart move obviously
this takes care of rook takes c8 cause
of Queen f1 mate rook e1 Queen f2 now it
becomes very very difficult to stop
ideas like moving the bishop and Knight
coming in and yeah difficult so the game
concluded with Queen d3 Bishop a6 again
for the third time trying to move the
Queen away to the bishop so you can take
on f3 and this time it's answered this
way and 93
that's it I think that here big it
actually ends here but I saw an another
source that the game continued here and
here in our position here
yeah we can dedicate this to be a master
been fibrils who says always play Bishop
reform although usually he means it in
the other side of the board
yeah so again a very coffeehouse like
gay by night again this is one of her
early games this game was played many
many years ago as you can see in 61 ok
she was much much younger so an
impressive style and now we will see a
game where she beat Judit Polgar we'll
see what you think so efore b5 9 f 3 9 f
6 d4 one of the wildest slides in this
opening and you will see how it
continues 97 takes takes castles Queen
h4 this is all theory old theory still
till today if this is from 1990 I think
right yeah in the novice at Olympia c4
so basically this like I already a race
black is gonna go left white already
went white and this pressure on the
centre is well trying to undermine the
knight castles c5 again we find that for
our lecture like I always like to say I
can talk about the indicates of the
position why this move and not that move
but here of course Azure is a race one
side is trying to attack the King on
this side the other one at the other
side and watch what happens here
upon g5 again one of the more aggressive
lines I don't know the theory at some
point around here it's still theory I
know Bishop g7
92 route 88 somewhere around here my
theory ends so if this if somebody can
contribute beyond them they'll be great
but otherwise we're just seeing the game
so Queen e1 this will run not familiar
with of course the idea is that white is
a bit concerned about ideas like rookie
six eight six
if that happens very fast he's going to
also go very fast so he's trying to
preempt it by trading Queen the Queen
trade will be very very welcome here so
Queen here
none are retreated with a knight so that
after Eaton
it will not be under attack Queen d2
trying to take advantage of the fact
table on g5 is under hit and they can be
taken Knight goes back and she plays the
aggressive move Queen a5 I suppose if
she would have played here Queen e1
maybe we will never have seen this game
ever
so Queen a5 now the battle really begins
so King b8 a forced necessity obviously
f3 Knight back to f6 g3 this is all
questionable this idea I think is a bit
questionable I don't know exactly what
the fear was I don't know maybe she was
afraid of rook takes e - I'm assuming
she wanted to play d4 but was afraid of
rookie - Bishop e2 Queen d4 and Queen
takes a one that's the only thing i can
assume and therefore should try to
change the queen away but this is my
opinion is a weakness that's just not
not well placed so still when i play at
the level of Judit Polgar are plays it
you know it was after some thought queen
h5 a 4-year sergeant Judit Polgar is
white and not an apprentice really is
black so nie g4 now we start in this
position again it looks like it's gonna
be erased because white is going to go
b4 b5 c6 if this happens black is just
gonna
well die right or b6 this is going to be
too much too much initiative around the
the King and you wonder how to continue
here as black but she shows immediately
nice g4 now some moves some sacrifices
you play and you kind of wonder if your
opponent will take them or not and if
you can but here you know that there's
just no way to decline the sacrifice so
takes Bishop takes attacking me to
Knight therefore again playing very very
aggressively because I'm about to take
on d4 there's no way to defend that
practically - is hanging and you can
some of you might already feel optically
just by looking at it that the Queen
alone or a5 is not enough to attack the
white king this
this array the rooks are disconnected
the bishop hasn't moved yet and it just
have that feeling that sense that black
is gonna hit first even though she's
down a piece it's obvious that the
initiative is worth every bit of it so
Judith is trying to defend probably the
only try Bishop takes d4 check King g2
and of course this needs to be taken and
take okay so far yes yes to h3 the
knight is attacking in that's why the
night needs to be eliminated and it was
eliminated so now the question is hope
to continuous block because again just
by looking at the position one can sense
the black is doing really really well on
the other hand white there's ideas of
Iran Bishop takes c7 and d8 is weak and
a7 is weak and there are chances so what
to play no no I'm positive already saw
it there's no you can play a move like
Knight g4 without without seeing already
this position and she simply played
Bishop e5 just a simple defensive move
now we can see that the white position
down upon Bishop h3 is threatened
winning in exchange and things are just
not looking up so desperate on tests but
measures b5 again hard to believe that
this move is going to work especially
when there's a bishop always coming to
c8 but she makes sure that now maybe
it's the sabotaging to play check King
moves Bishop takes Queen b5 this could
end up really really poorly for black so
Bishop c8 again very very patient to
defensive moves I think this is really a
design of just maturity in this position
because here you think yourself well can
I just second or by playing something
aggressive or should I just play one
defensive move and now just go crazy
[ __ ] the pastry or something but now
simple defensive move and now white is
just losing
Queen before trying to do something
Bishop d6 again a very very clever move
Queen went to b3 and now it was time to
take takes roof e3 just a beautiful in
my opinion just a very very smart way of
conducting the attack completely
repulsing any chances on the Queen side
on the other hand the white position the
white team's position looks like
something unenviable now I want to play
stuff like rook de 8 and rookie to check
at the right time I also want to play
well check on h3 also at the absolute
right time is going to mate after
doubling the rooks so Queen c2 check
here roof takes g3 again I think that
after kee g1 rook takes g3 would have
been even stronger it would have been
with check right so takes everything so
here here see b7 takes rook takes f7
again Judith is trying to do the best
that you can or the worse that you can I
should say and it looks like maybe she's
getting away
now c7 is under attack and again the
black misses looks like they're not
working well together so what what are
we going to do we know there's a bishop
on the long diagonal threatening some
some interesting stuff but if d4 check
Bishop e4 is not going to be enough or
not what do you think well
simple again just an amazing to me I
mean the beautiful the beauty of this
game is not only the aggressive move in
the sacrifices but also the quiet moves
Bishop e5 Bishop c8 and now she just
takes the time to play rook c8 just like
it's almost like a slap in the face just
when you think you might have generated
some counter play she plays one quite
more and she says okay I have my same
threats as before it's your move
good luck be a worse so she tried Bishop
to b5 again she needs to do something
against the idea of something like d4
Bishop b4 d3 now it's really gonna kick
because c7 is protected so she tries to
block this way but now of course the
ending is very simple she plays d4 check
bishop c6 and one more move in she
resigned beautiful rook c3 to think that
the best player in the world is playing
with four women player in the world is
playing with the white pieces this just
looks like a masterpiece beautiful
beautiful game combining attacking
movement defensive moves just in a smart
way so pretty impressive performance for
dessert you're gonna see a beautiful
game very short but really sweet and
then we can go to go on to buy a tribute
that means this is a very short and
sweet game I'm going to show it to you
with very little remarks because it's
self-explanatory this is a game she's
playing an opponent in the Georgian
championship of 1969 really really nice
okay this is going to be our starting
position and of course the normal person
will play g3 Queen h3 maybe King f2
queen f1 you know play some regular
chest no na is not thinking like that
sacrificing the first pawn queen takes
by the way this should have been a draw
and her brilliancy is recommended by the
computer but just for a draw but again
humans have difficulty so here here
councils 97 so at first we look at this
position we think okay she shot she
sucked the F pawn but did she really get
a lot for it
watch what happens first she goes here
just in case black had nefarious ideas
like counseling and 96 the normal move
again it telling to castle and things
are looking very normal you're probably
already thinking how to continue should
i go rook F - should I go Queen e2 Queen
d2 does it make sense to go with the
bishop somewhere Bishop f6 for example
yeah the but this is but this should be
a draw so the combination she plays is
beautiful but so she plays here okay you
guys play too much bughouse
so you put a knight on h5 yeah so of
course I suggest to take otherwise it's
becoming more expensive and now in the
spirit of bughouse Ruth takes f7
obviously the natural move and now this
is not a good move this is losing who
can tell me what is the defensive move
but this is a very non baghouses move
okay that's a hint because that's it's
what may be the least baghouses move no
Arlen nope
the computer only gives one defensive
move here I was really curious but after
it says draw by some amazing maneuver
yes
that's a bit over-ambitious I said I
said not back house game nutbag asthma
of Quinte xh 2 here's as buggers as it
gets
Arjun one more chance nope 86 86 yes and
I think the game continues something
like quintics age 5 and if you take here
then there's a king deaerated like some
repetition Queen h4 Queen h5 and it's a
draw how exactly I don't remember but
I'm sure that we can look at it
so here what can even cheat to save time
kids have a lot of games to show you and
yeah so Bishop before Bishop e5 and
after takes King ass to move away yeah
yeah draw
however the non-computer opponent fell
right into this the what not the engine
it spoils everything what's that like
that okay so yeah the surprise was the
route can five of course if you take
queen h5 yeah not good so the only way
to play on is Queen takes r5 but it's
not very appetizing its he yeah I don't
know if you resigned but that's where
the game ends I don't get any more moves
maybe he resigned I would I know that I
would have been demoralized enough to
resign here yeah of course after pawn
takes Queen takes h5 why is it whistling
and that's not the move the mouse is
refusing to play this for here we go
yeah yeah this is difficult you know
that yeah
that was nice that was like something
from Young Frankenstein
yeah all right on we go to Maya and I
don't know how many games of my I'm
going to be able to insert so we're
gonna move very fast this is a game
against a large portage where the time
was maybe not even speak because already
1998 98 when they played and at one time
of course she was one of the best
players in the world but it's very nice
very nice performance so playing into a
normal Quinn's Indian
and okay lots of analysis that we're
going to skip Bishop to c1 repositioning
the Bishop rook b8 Bishop b2 8 6 will be
1 C 5 so far normal ie 397 OC month here
so until now we played I mean this is
the ideas here nothing is new typical
hanging pawns position from blacks point
of view white plays the normal Queen
Satya inside everything is good right
now white there's nothing to complain
about but watch what she does again
look how aggressive play against
positional structure sometimes really
pays off
first of all retreat so the night is not
pinned or anything and there's no tricks
and now this is the one comment that
analysis that I'm going to I'm going to
go over and it's a pretty surprised the
pottage didn't go 95 mainly because now
both the Queen and the night are very
annoying placed and there's no g6
because I might think g6 and 96 is
hanging instead he opted for the more
passive maneuver 91 again trying to
reposition the night the right time
maybe going 93 94 he is trying to lure
the pawns to advance as we well know in
in hanging pawns situation white always
wants to see one of those pawns advance
because if you advance the C pawn then
this becomes backwards
you have this girl forever and Bishop e7
is weak if you advance the d4 pawn many
times it can be captured several times
and again sometimes the c-4 square can
be used but here g6 heating the Queen
Queen back rook b8 protecting the bishop
on b7 and now d4 is very very hard to
stop why should have done should have we
have to grade the lights that he did to
try to stop it because just I guess
underestimated what's gonna happen 92 94
93 again lots of ideas but g5 simply
stopping not f4 but not only watch the
pawns on the King side and what happened
so yeah now they mentioned to move g4
stopping all the pawns is a good move
Queen a1 route B to c8
and now again last chance to play g4
because that still stops the idea of c4
instead this was played and now Nona
comes into action until now lots of
maneuvering maybe not much excitement
but now watch out she despised these
patches of someone who was one of the
best players in the world one time
f5 95 h5 that makes sure that the g4
square is extra protected no hops for
many pieces of pawns there and now after
the last mistake f3 well what should
have been done is of course f4 as it
says so f3 takes takes d4 Bishop a5 rook
default f4 now but now it's a bit late
now of course she takes if takes takes
takes here and therefore is coming of
course huge compensation I mean those
pawns are going to be really really
embarrassing to stop and alternatively
she took on he took on b7 roofdeck c3
and again analysis show that if take
stakes here here and the queen is coming
to the long diagonal that's very very
hard to meet so Bishop to D to G takes a
for now is the last chance it looks like
really scary to take the rook on e3 but
that should have been done there was no
other choice and she didn't do it for
some reason
but again taking on c8 and taking only
three would have been the best practical
chance G takes f for was played look
sorry that one too fast rookie to Queen
B one Queen to d7 just remarkable she's
just playing for an attack and gets it
yes sergeant Dave a question Queen where
King H one I have a bishop on the long
diagonal yeah that's what that's exactly
what she wants to get rid of so Bishop
f3 d3
again I'm growing a bit fast because I
really want to show through the other
game that is coming but you can see that
she's playing very actively very
aggressively protecting your port on the
6th rank and very hard and now another
exchange sacrifice she was giving how
many exchange did you sacrifice in this
game on c8 only 3 now on f3 takes Queen
check a beautiful sacrifice some of you
might know the famous that will be a
Fischer sacrifice of a queen on f4 this
time it's a knight and you can do
whatever you want take it don't take it
the king is already in trouble in the
game we didn't take because after takes
check here doesn't look nice so she
played oops
he played rook to g1 King here with the
idea from g8 if I could have played a
game like this against polish I would
have given a lot so rookie one roof g8
takes check and Bishop e5 resigns
because after takes here
very discouraging position
because it's 1998 that was post peak
that's what that that was one of those
veterans ladies mattress that they used
to hold in the late nineties nowadays
she is in her late 50s I guess or six
yeah yeah now we're going to see her not
a beautiful women against Milan ook a
Russian Grand Master again look at his
performance III this probably is the
best game say again 82 82 so he is a
pretty serious Grandmaster but wise 24
30 I thought he will be even higher
rated yeah yeah so we have the normal
green felt Queen a five kalsa now we
know that Queen takes 82 Bishop g5 is
probably the main argument favored by
many games of Kramnik as white but black
is now testing with Queen takes c3 d5 a
very nice positional sacrifice Queen
retreats Bishop g5 again a standard move
to try to cause some chaos on the
kingside Queen c7 who in c1 normal
okay this is a bit much I know maybe
she's playing a little bit
optimistically but as you will see again
aggression pays off
he 597 rookie Juan objectively black is
not doing very badly here and just extra
pawn and is still defending white is an
impressive center but it shouldn't
really go that far Knight b6 d6 again
very very ambitious pawn takes pawn
takes rook e8 h3 Bishop d7 okay this
will have a bit critical about I think
that Bishop e6 would have been a much
more testing move a it keeps the file
closed it keeps an eye on this diagonal
and this pawn and takes care of some
very important squares those squares and
especially this diagonal is very very
relevant I think that he just played a
bit optimistically he didn't realize he
thought okay she has a point
I mean I have a pawn she has some
initiative it's going to take a long
time before I can either cash in on the
pawn or she will try to prove her
superiority
he just didn't didn't appreciate what
was about to happen to him so here
Bishop h6 okay and again a bit of a
callous move in my opinion Bishop h8 9
g5 because White's attack is developing
very quickly right now you can see it
that's the brilliancy of this game you
think what could be bad about blacks
position well you take a look in to
three moves and you will see yes but
when you have time not when you don't
have time no no definitely not Bishop
takes I'm trying to remember what what
went on here um you might be able to
still play it you might still be able to
play it it's very important to avoid
what happened in the game because in the
game what happened was after this Knight
g5 already there is a lot of pressure
this is already in my opinion becoming
very very difficult the opponent played
Bishop f5 that's an outright mistake but
I think that already there's some
element where I'm going to play Bishop
b5 and my knife is hitting a 6 if you go
Bishop e6 that's already
I think the black already in my opinion
maybe missed the boat or at this close
enough now White's initiative is very
strong I've I like white in this
position
before it was just the game that
compensation for the pawn but now it's
no longer that so this was played and in
this position it should become obvious
now come to exchange sacrifices first of
all takes this one we don't need this
junk right after this now Bishop c4 the
whole point I wanted to conquer the
diagonal that's right and I'm
threatening Bishop of 7 with a better
game how to stop it even I don't know
you're about to lose everything y'all
here so here only move and now listen I
do need my knight and there's no way
you're getting my Bishop so there's
another rook for you just like a month's
I mean to think you're playing a
grandmaster and you're doing this this
is like how much more fun can it be so
here
Queen f4 again threatening a little
visit to f7 just fine just phenomenal so
what to do in this position Queen d7 I
think it's the only move nothing really
else to do and okay it looks like your
pieces are at maximum capacity right
answer
no Bishop e5 as if it was not enough to
give two exchanges now he just delivers
the final blow and after Bishop here
resigned
what to play what to do you have to play
rook a d8 rue Cafe to play Bishop f8 and
then rookie faith takes and takes I'm up
a piece and the pawn on d6 is looking
cool yeah I mean just a masterpiece true
black didn't play the most stubborn
defense maybe but very impressive finish
given here yeah you know here before my
night went to g5 I still think Bishop e6
but my d5 maybe maybe anything would
have been better than just giving me the
time to build my g5 and get a Bishop to
c4 ok since we still have some time very
quickly will see the last desert and
this is I'm not going to show you the
whole game well at least I'm gonna
really Brooke breeze through it she only
played Nigel short two times she played
him in 1993 in 1995 the result to zero
now we talk about guide it was like a
candidate so pretty impressive so I
don't think the reading is all right I
don't think Short was 25 10 and 83 I
think it was much higher rate but Nick
maybe I'm wrong
more likely so he's playing the
classical caro-kann and uh what if I
lost and type caro-kann takes and she
plays a very quiet variation but watch
what happens from it Queen c7 to stop
Bishop f4 9 f3 or another three Bishop
c4 c4 e6 castles 97 d5 already the sign
of aggression again every time she has a
chance she immediately put some oil into
the fire objective is that the best move
maybe not maybe you should play quietly
like b3 Bishop b2 be a little more
patient about it or oftentimes
especially in the younger years she was
never shy from a fine so castles
normal pawn takes c6 95 again everything
is normal here now if white just plays
the move like Queen b3 and I go back F
takes c6 black really has nothing to
complain about so she plays 92 again
objectively I'm not saying these are the
best moves or she's playing a like a
brilliant game but she is just seeking a
fight and willing to compromise a little
bit together I think when you're not
playing Carlsen or a computer that's not
a bad strategy
so Bishop took back on e6 Queen a4
aggressive and short doesn't bother to
defend opponent on a 794 Bishop takes e4
I have to tell you this move should have
been very very good for black obviously
after Bishop takes e4 Knight f3 check
and queen h2 mate is very very
convincing so for a moment she looks
like she's in trouble and she is but
look what happened here here she just
gives up an exchange this is not
justified by the way like I said I'm not
showing you the game I'm breathing to
the game to get to the position where
she did something very very impressive
so 93 Queen 8 725
Bishop e3 Queen takes Knight check check
here here okay so the King is telling a
little travel and objectively it should
not be enough it should be at best I
think I don't know if you it should be a
draw very close to a draw after taking
the night but he managed to do something
very very nice
so before again what else to play
because nothing else working on Tobruk
c1 queen a5 did the he just hides so
before takes of course Knight takes rook
c1 is looking different and Queen takes
I just take the knight on d3 I guess
yeah so
say again let's take a look
okay first of all let me verify that I
really want to play Queen d3 which I
didn't lie
oh yeah of course I take care because I
take on f7 on GA yeah there's no Queen C
for ya difficult so King King took
Bishop f3 we moved check and now I think
he played a very optimistic move Knight
B - that should loose I think that the
right move was king somewhere King c3 or
king c5 one of those boos and he is
actually surviving it should be it
shouldn't win but what he missed was
very very neat he missed it after this
check here she has this move and after
Queen takes Queen 85 looks like me so
yeah so short was unhappy he you could
on I can only imagine his face somewhere
around here so b5 here
yes sergeant sure here by the way black
design to wear
right
did you hear wine yeah
Houdini yeah
so after this just gave over and she
beat some other mega character Oh guys
guys thank you very much for attending
the class I hope you enjoyed it